foreign
[Music]
once again
the White House honors the Greek
American community
family with roots deep in Hellas
in Cyprus
in Asia Minor
by honoring the immortal Heroes of 1821.
and The Rebirth of Greece
Mr President
you have been long a close and trusted
friend of the omahena of the Greek
American community
a cause for deep appreciation and
affection
you started this long friendship with
the Greeks of Wilmington Delaware
and you have reached out Across the
Nation and across the oceans even
to give your wise counsel
to offer your solidarity and your
reciprocal Arab Your Love
through the decades
to be with you here at the White House
celebrating the resurrection of the
Greek Nation
is an extraordinary honor for all of us
and on behalf of all I thank you from
the bottom of my heart
[Applause]
but Mr President
you are so much more than our beloved
friend
you have shown yourself to be a true
champion for Freedom around the world
particularly on behalf of our Ukrainian
brothers and sisters
who are fighting for their very lives
against inhuman and irrational
aggression
you have stood with Ukraine on every
step of this long and difficult path and
for that we are also very grateful
[Applause]
also as children of the mother Church of
Constantinople
whose unparalleled leader his own
Holiness our ecumenical patriarch
Bartholomew your friend
count you Mr President our patriarch as
a true friend
we have thus caused for even more
thankfulness for that
we thank you for your strong support of
the purely spiritual mission of The
ecumenical patriarchy which is a mission
of love a mission of Peace a mission of
hope that is needed now more than ever
thank you
Mr President
you are the leader
you are the leader of this great nation
and at the same time the leader of the
Free World
where you stand at the Forefront of the
Phalanx for freedom
and we we are here to tell you today
that you do not stand alone
where you have all of us at least the
whole world is with you the Free World
thank you Mr President for your courage
to speak and to do what is just and true
thank you for your love for Greece and
Cyprus
and for Hellenism wherever it may be
thank you for your support for a
rules-based international order
thank you for standing with our
community Through the many years of your
outstanding public service
we are with you Mr President as Greeks
and As Americans just as the heroes of
1821 were inspired by those Heroes of
1776.
may God bless you Mr President together
with the First Lady
together with your family
and with our Nations Armed Forces
bless you with health
long life bless you with his grace and
his strength
Long Live America
long live the Greek people
Zito ielada
[Applause]
Archbishop thank you very much for those
kind words and as she began by
explaining why
this may be the first Greek American
event that my wife Jill's not been with
me
but she is uh down in Tennessee with the
families
of uh of those who were killed and that
god-awful attack
and uh she apologized for not being able
to be with you
but uh let me just say that um
my sister valzers was with me so I have
the
the better part of the family I used to
be three years older than Val now I'm 20
years old in about
we went to the same University together
I graduated she graduated honors that's
not a joke
she managed every one of my campaigns
since I was in high school and but so
anyway I want to acknowledge my sister
who's the best part of the family and I
want to
and uh Archbishop
I want to say that I've
I've found that uh the two most
christ-like figures I've ever met
whereas all Holiness and the Pope
and their friends they've talked to he's
the pope has talked to me about the
friendship and the pope is ill now so
say an extra prayer for him but he still
wonders why as a Roman Catholic I bless
myself this way
you know I've been I've been hanging
around it's all your fault
I uh you all think I'm kidding not
not really it was uh where's John
sarbanes is he here
oh he went to vote well John sarbanes's
dad Paul was uh it's hard to believe but
Junior to me and seniority but my
educator Paul was a brilliant guy and uh
I owe Paul all that I know about Greece
and the involvement for deep involvement
for so many years and uh but I wanted to
say hello to John look uh it's wonderful
to welcome all of you to the White House
to celebrate 202 years of Greek
Independence and all the great
contributions Greek and Greek Americans
have made to our country
the world owes a great deal of debt to
Greece including the Revolutionary idea
of democracy and it was revolutionary at
the time which continues to deliver for
the people to this day
in fact earlier today I was co-hosting
the second International Summit of
democr for democracy
and uh democracies and Nations around
the world came together to commit
ourselves to defending democracy and
that was done early today
so it's great to have all of you here in
this special day
reminisce is a it's an honor to see you
and so many represented the Greek
Orthodox
Archdiocese of America again I also want
to welcome the ambassador of Greece and
Cyprus and our own ambassador to Grace
George soonest George where are you
there he is
and by the way there's a very important
Republican and former administrations in
the days when we used to really like
each other
I still do
how you doing buddy good to see you Tom
Tom Carr logus
Tom and I spent a whole heck of a lot of
hours arguing and then shaking hands
right before time I good to see you pal
it's great to see you and if you'll
excuse a point of personal privilege as
we used to say in the Senate it's great
to be here with friends like Father Alex
father I'm going to ruin your reputation
like talking
and the only reason I ran for president
and got elected was so I could award him
the presidential medal of freedom last
year
thank you Father
as a matter of fact father I still
haven't figured out are you the reason
I've been made in our con is that what
happened
I don't I don't know but you've been a
great friend for a long time and your
family as well has been great friends of
Morris and uh I'm here with my president
of the Biden Institute a guy named
Dennis asanas who was the president of
the University of Delaware but the real
power is his wife and uh both of you
stand up I want everybody to see you
guys these are from Delaware
and great friends like Andy Mike manitos
and they're a big part of the reason my
Greek American instituents in Delaware
sometimes refer to me as as the man
sitting behind you father who helped me
my very first campaign directly behind
you was I the nickname I got early on
when I won by 3 200 votes and for the
senate seat when I was 29 years old is
because I started to call me Joe
bidenopoulos because oh you think I'm
kidding I'm not I'm not joking am I I'm
not joking because of the overwhelming
support from the Greek American
community and uh and I'm a little
worried my sister's sitting next to Tom
Hanks uh
but Tom welcome pal welcome I want to
begin today by acknowledging
all the families across Greek Greece who
are grieving loved ones lost during the
train accident in Tempe it was a tragic
tragic accident and they're in our
prayers and Jill and I and the American
people were deeply saddened by this
tragedy and our prayers continue to be
with the Greek people including all
those lost loved ones and those who
recovering from those injuries
and this afternoon we honor the Deep
History of the United Nations we and
honor the lives that were cut short last
month as well
thousands of years ago uh ancient Greek
philosopher Socrates said and he's said
to discussed a simple yet profound
wisdom he said know thyself
know thyself
well to truly know America you have to
know the history and our hopes you have
to know a little about Greece to really
understand it Greece is woven to the
very foundations of our democracy of our
nation we see across this this city from
The Columns of the Capitol to the to the
figures that flank the Supreme Court
inspired by Demas and uh the Greek
goddess of law of justice and Law And
Justice and more than that we feel in
our nation's Soul because we are
governed As We the People
the United States is the only nation in
the world built on an idea an idea
Every Other Nation of the world is based
on geography ethnicity or religion but
we're based on an idea and it's not
hyperbole to suggest that the idea that
we're all created equal
we hold these truth to be self-evident
that all men and women are created equal
endowed by our creator with certain
inalemable rights life liberty no other
nation is based on an idea
and it was essentially a Greek idea
early on I really mean it it was Greek
and all those years ago that inspired
the framers to believe in this radical
idea and to build to build a nation
around it
years after American independence this
is the same idea the brave Greek
Patriots to fight their own freedom for
their own Freedom as well laying the
groundwork for a future that would make
both our Nations proud
so today and every day Greek
Independence is a celebration for
Americans and Greeks alike
it gives us a chance to honor this
history and binds Us in the values that
unite us Liberty equality dignity and
democracy and democracy throughout our
shared history every generation has to
step up and protect those values against
democracies moral Memorial foes you know
I learned in graduate school and
undergraduate school about as a
political science and history major that
democracy had to be protected by every
generation
and I used to think it was more
hyperbole than anything else but it need
be every generation is nothing automatic
about democracy nothing automatic about
it and we saw this during World War II
when Greece and the United Greek the
United States bought fought the forces
of fascism we saw in the Cold War when
our people stood as one to Prevail
against communism and we see it today as
our nation's stand together to support
the brave people of Ukraine as I fight
for the same values Greeks and American
Patriots did all those years ago Liberty
dignity dignity
dignity not just the Liberty dignity and
democracy simply put as allies and
partners and friends we've proven time
and again that we aren't just inheritors
of democracy we're as champions
we're as champions
and that's thanks to the large parts of
the courage and character of the Greek
American community
you know throughout my career I've been
lucky to see this courage and character
up close
I see in the Greek Orthodox Archdiocese
of America which has always stood up for
social justice and civil rights I've
seen in the leaders across the Greek
American Community have always LED with
heart and with hope
none more consequential in my view none
more consequential than Paul sarbanes as
I said earlier he was a guy who uh who
educated me most of all I've seen in the
character and courage of millions of
Greek immigrants who've always enriched
what it means to be American
as I said earlier our country owes debt
of to the founders of the Greek
democracy and the first that taught us
we the people
to hold power to shape our destiny but
you know we all owe a great deal to
Greek families like so many viewers who
left everything behind to push that
Destiny Ever forward
who generation after generation have
strive to make our nation more free and
more fair
you know across our country have framed
the flame of Liberty and fanned it and
started to flicker in Athens a thousand
years ago and now it burns brightly here
today
let's recommit to our work and by the
way we have the head of the committee I
once chaired the Foreign Relations
Committee we've got a guy sitting over
there I think is Greek who is uh who is
Miley
stand up
and there's two things you got to know
about them one he's smarter than you and
two he's tough
good to see you man thanks for being
here and folks look at this moment where
our world is a you've many of you heard
me say this before Madam Ambassador but
uh we're the world's at an inflection
point
you're going to see things that are
going to the next three to five years in
the last three or four or five years is
going to determine what the next four or
five decades are going to look like
we go through this period every five or
six generations and we're at that point
now the world is changing it's changing
significantly we have an opportunity we
have an opportunity to continue to be
the keepers of the flame if we do it
well
so let's work together to show that
knowing America knowing ourselves means
working for the future for great with
Greater Hope equality and a possibility
for people around the world
I I actually know we can do it and the
Chairman's heard me say this many times
I've never been more optimistic about
our future than I am today I really mean
it we have such an enormous opportunity
not just for the United States but to
change the nature of how we deal in this
Hemisphere and around the world
because we're the United States of
America we've got to remember that where
the United States America there is
nothing nothing beyond our capacity
nothing if we set our mind to it I
really mean it not a single thing
as long as we do it together and I can
think of No Greater group of people to
do with the Greek American community so
happy Independence Day to you and your
friends God bless you all and before the
reception begins we have a performance
for you and I'm not even going to tell
you who it is I'm going to say but thank
you thank you thank you all let's bring
let's bring out somebody who Tom knows
well thank you
[Applause]